Okay. I would like to nominate my
favorite Spider-Man villain as Spellcheck.
Yeah.
And can we all agree that the first draft of
this character was known as Grammar Nazi? Like,
maybe? There's no way he wasn't,
right? There's no way he wasn't.
Tom, excuse me. I hate to correct
you. But the first draft of this
character was the paper clip from
Microsoft Word that yells at you.
Oh, Clippy.
Clippy was the first draft of Spellcheck.
Oh, my gosh. Nina, who is your pick for
dumbest Spider-Man villain of all time?
Thanks, Brian. So I did a little research
today. Tom's not doing well, I don't think.
I'm doing great. I'm doing terrific.
All right. And I'm sure that you two will chime in
because I'm talking to two bonafide comic experts,
but I found a really dumb villain
on our list at looper.com.
And I found a favorite fact about him,
but the gist is his name is Typeface
and he first appeared in Peter Parker: Spider-Man,
Volume Two #23 in 2000 and actually I have two-
A comic book I bought off the rack.
Nice.
I remember buying that.
Actually, I lied. I have two facts that I
love about Typeface, but then I'm curious
about more stuff about Typeface.
So basically he puts letters on
his face and he also uses letters to
kill people. Am I correct in this?
Yeah. Well, he used his letters to beat people up.
Right. But he puts an R or an A on his
face, and the R is for retribution and
the A's for annihilation. And I'm
like, "Those are the only..." Yeah.
But I found two really great facts
about him that I'm obsessed with.
Can I pause right here,
before you tell us the fact?
Yeah.
Wouldn't it have been a cooler villain
if he just put an R on his forehead and
called himself Retribution and got
rid of all the rest of the stuff?
Yeah. None of the rest of the stuff is necessary.
It's just letters, just for- because he used-
He just used regular knives or guns?
I don't want to say why because you might be about
to tell us that right now. So, go
ahead. What's your favorite fact?
Well, he feels like that villain in the
first Austin Powers movie who throws a shoe
and he's just like, who throws his shoe?
Random Task.
Thank you. Random Task. Okay. So
the first fact that I loved is,
after they try to explode him and he doesn't die,
he becomes a vigilante and he inspires another
vigilante who names himself Spellcheck.
Yeah. I checked that one out.
What?
That sucks. That's the worst thing
I've ever heard. I hate it so much.
I'd say. Somebody buried the lead pretty hard on
this. Let's talk Spellcheck.
What's Spellcheck's deal?
I'm sharing the picture in our chat right now.
Oh, boy.
No way. This guy rocks.
Whoa, wait with great power, there
must also come great vocabulary.
There you go.
That is money right there.
Oh, man.
Verbiage beware.
Every editor in the world just screamed.
So Spellcheck shows up in one issue of Tangled
Web of Spider-Man, which is sort of the-
That makes sense.
That's dope.
There it is. So Tom knows this as the comic book
that's about Spider-Man's tertiary... It's
like, "Hey Spider-Man's cool. What about
stuff that happens around Spider-Man when he's not
there?" So that's kind of what's going on here.
It was like Black Mirror,
but with Spider-Man as the-
So basically, they were like,
"Do you love Spider-Man?"
They were like, "Do you love Spider-Man,
but you want less Spider-Man?"
That's 100% what it was.
It was this bizarre, creative writing class
sort of playground for writers where they
got to do... They did like a Flowers
for Algernon story, where the Rhino
got really smart for two issues, and then realized
that it's a lot easier to be a dumb villain.
Sure.
So in this comic book that I checked out before
our chat, because I saw that fact too. Because
I remembered Typeface from a million years
ago when I got the comic and then I saw,
"Oh and he inspired a vigilante named Spellcheck."
I was like, "Shut up." And so I looked at it
and it's just this one issue with a very
stylized art style. So that's why in this
picture he looks like a zombie. He's meant
to just be a normal man, but his whole deal,
the only way that he's a vigilante is that he's
just out to get people who use bad grammar.
Okay. I would like to nominate my
favorite Spider-Man villain as Spellcheck.
And can we all agree that the first draft of
this character was known as Grammar Nazi? Like,
maybe? There's no way he wasn't.
Right? There's no way he wasn't.
Tom, excuse me. I hate to correct
you. But the first draft of this
character was the paper clip from
Microsoft Word that yells at you.
Oh, Clippy.
Clippy was the first draft of Spellcheck.
Oh, my gosh. I'd like to see a
team up with Clippy and Spellcheck.
Oh, man.
"It looks like you're trying
not to die." I love that.
Yeah, but you know what? For all of Spellcheck's
faults, I bet he murdered people when they
screwed up sneak peek, P-E-E-K, versus sneak
peek, P-E-A-K, which is a thing people do.
Basically, all he did in this one issue that
he appeared in is that he chased Typeface down.
He's like, "Oh, I can help you." And then
Typeface is like, "You're too weird for me."
This is a man who's covered in
letters and beating people up
with letters. And he's like,
"Get out of here, you freak."
I love it. "You freak," yeah.
And then at the end, he beats up Spellcheck and
hangs him from a light post, like Spider-Man,
and leaves a note saying, "From your
friendly neighborhood Typeface."
Wow.
And Spider-Man finds it, and he's like, "Well,
that's weird." And that's the whole thing.
Wait, he just uses the same catch
phrase and just puts his name into it?
He doesn't even come up with
anything more interesting?
That's the joke that they were doing. It's fine.
I love it.
It's one of those strange things. So Typeface, I
was reading that comic book that Typeface first
shows up in. I think that was the comic, the issue
that made me not interested in that comic book
anymore. Because I was just like, "Am I supposed
to take this guy seriously?" Because he seems
like he's being depicted as very deadly and
as a formidable foe for Spider-Man, like he
beats up and knocks out Spider-Man in their first
encounter. But he's just some clown who's covered
himself in letters and has knives that look
like letters. I don't know, he just sucks. So
the reason that he's Typefaces is because he used
to be a sign painter. That's his big origin story.
So he came back from Vietnam, and I guess his wife
left him, and his brother died, and he started a
sign painting business. And then someone bought
his sign painting business, and I guess fired him.
And he got really mad about it. And now he's
a villain who paints himself with letters.
And he needed some of that R for retribution. I'll
tell you what surprises me the
most about the story, Brian,
is that you owned the first appearance
of Typeface and you've chosen to just
keep working for a living, when you could
have sold that and been a millionaire.
Owned, past tense. Oh no, I'm sure I
sold that many years ago for a nickel.
That's gone. That's gone.
Unbelievable.
Missed opportunity.
I used to work at that comic shop and every so
often I would haul in my old comics and be like,
"I don't need these anymore. I'm in college."
And they'd give me some comic book credit
and on I would go. That issue has been gone
for literal decades now. It's been gone.
So Brian, can I ask you a question about
something else I found about Typeface?
You can try. I won't promise I'll
know an answer, but give it a shot.
So a fact that I found, "fact," I don't know
if it's true because I saw it on Wikipedia and
I tried to trace it to the source and
it's gone. But apparently Paul Jenkins,
who is one of the writers of this comic
said that if and when Typeface dies,
the only guarantee we have is his
eyes will turn into little X's.
That's cute.
And I was just like, "It's appalling
that you have to tell us that."
I mean, it's cute that he said that.
Was anyone laying awake at night being
like, "But will his eyes turn into X's?"
I would have. I would have gotten there.
I'm sure they asked him that. I'm
sure that probably came up in the
same way where it's like, "Hey,
we get to interview Paul Jenkins,
the creator of the century, the writer of the
influential Inhumans comic." And they're like,
"So let me ask you about this villain you
made, Typeface." And he's like, "Oh man.
I mean, I had to write something
that day." And that's probably...
His publicist is like, "No
more Typeface questions."
I'm sure it's the same thing where like when
they ask the people who wrote the best episode
of Star Trek ever, Threshold, whenever they
talk to them about that episode, the one where
Tom Paris turned into a lizard and abducted
Captain Janeway and turned her into a lizard,
and then they both had lizard babies. I'm sure
it's the same kind of thing where it's like,
"You've had a great career working in
Star Trek. Let me ask you about this
one horribly embarrassing thing." You have
to own it. So Paul Jenkins has to own it.
George Clooney always gets
asked about Batman and Robin.
Always. He's still talking about it.
Yeah. It's what you do.
George Clooney has had such a great career.
And if anyone gives him guff over Batman,
like you're missing the point,
man. It's fine. Leave him alone.
A combined 36 Oceans. I mean
the guy has done good work.
So many Oceans.
Yeah, but he's like the last old Hollywood
figure we have. And everybody's like,
"So what about the nipples on the Batman suit?"
Like still, they're still asking him about it.
There are a lot of villains on this list
here that I like, over on looper.com.
We've got the Spider-Queen who was
actually in a storyline I really like,
which was Spider-Island where all the
residents of New York get turned into spiders,
spider people, and she's the
mastermind controlling everyone.
I was tempted by Spider-Queen because our article
says she can kill by screaming.
And I was like, "That's funny."
She has a screamy kill. There's also a lot of
characters on here I just don't know. Like,
I've read a lot of Spider-Man,
and I've never heard of Banjo.
Oh, Banjo, come on.
I've never heard of Banjo.
One appearance, one issue of
one comic back in the '80s.
I don't know Manslaughter Marsdale. I
don't know Sticks and Stone. But I do know,
I'll mention... You know what? I won't
mention some of the ones I do know,
because Tom, you picked from
this list too, didn't you?
I did. I did grab one from this list.
Why don't we flip to you for now?
Who did you pick from this list? So I don't
start talking about someone that you picked.
Oh, I feel like I promise that you
won't... There's basically nothing to say,
but I wish it had been Banjo.
Banjo's, I mean, gracious.
Whenever I hear Banjo, I think about Space Ghost
lamenting his dead aunt. Do you know that one?
The one that he just follows
around for the whole episode?
"Banjo." Tom, tell us who you picked. Tell
us something. Stop me from talking, please.
Okay. So I went back to this one. It's not
because this is a fascinating character, but
it's sort of representative of a lot of the
stuff that drives me crazy about comics.
I was a kid in the '90s. And I remember
not really getting to buy a lot of comics,
but definitely seeing them on the shelf. And you
would see a character and it would catch your eye,
catch your attention. And you'd be like, "Man, I
wonder what his deal is?" And then you'd have to
wait until you were an adult to actually find
out what the hell was going on with this dude?
And generally speaking, by the time there was
like a Wikipedia page dedicated to some trashcan
character, it was 20 years later. And you would
look it up and you'd feel that rush of excitement
that you got when you were a kid, and then realize
that this was just trash, that this was just
tail end of the '80s, a little bit
too much cocaine still in the systems
of these writers, evidently. There was not a lot
of great stuff. So 1992, it's the golden age of
sort of Todd McFarlane, "Let's toss too many
teeth on something and make it scary," aesthetic.
So Venom had come out four years earlier.
Earlier the same year, Carnage had showed up.
And then Marvel introduces this new
character called the Doppelganger, who's
very much in the same vein as Venom and
Carnage in that it's just a scarier looking
version of Spider-Man, only with the added
detail... There's basically nothing to him.
He's Spider-Man, but with six arms. So you got
the whole eight limbs thing, like a spider.
Oh, I was just about to ask how similar he was to
Tobey Maguire's goth Spider-Man in Spider-Man 3.
Very different. Similar dancing, but
that's where the similarities end.
Oh, okay. Cool.
If we can get anybody to animate like
Tobey Maguire, but with too many...
You've just nominated yourself, Tom.
Yeah. If we can get you to animate
whatever you're talking about.
So it's like the Spider-Man costume and
everything, but on an eight limb creature
with scary scratchy fingies and great
big bite-y teeth. He's got the fangities.
If you want to try and go into the back
story, it's exhausting. It's not fun.
He's a spider clone, right?
Nope.
No. Okay, I'm sorry.
No, you would think so, because this was-
Then I don't know anything about him.
No, this was the right time for
that sort of... No, this was...
It doesn't matter. A character called the Magus,
who's like a different version of Adam Warlock,
like an evil Adam Warlock, uses the technology
of another character named Anthropomorpho,
God, I hate the '90s, and uses it to make evil
versions of all of these Marvel characters.
And that's it. You wind up with just
panels and panels of Captain America,
but he's got scary sharp teeth and red eyes and a
buzz saw, instead of a shield. And Alpha Flight,
except they've all got red eyes, scary, sharp
teeth... Almost all of them were just people
the way that you were used to seeing them,
but with red eyes and scary, sharp teeth.
Cool.
And Spider-Man got one of them,
and he died immediately. Didn't have a
personality. He was just like a scary Spider-Man.
Too beautiful for this world.
Too pure. We didn't deserve him.
And then too beautiful and pure to stay
dead because they brought him back,
and sum total, he's done nothing the last
close to 30 years that he's been around.
He's done practically nothing. He shows
up every once in a while, and he's scary.
I remember a friend of mine had the action figure,
so obviously he stuck out in my mind.
But aside from that, he's just like...
I'll say this. He looks cool in that '90s sort
way if you are 13 and reading comic books.
Totally. Yeah, visually.
You're like, "Oh, yeah, that's cool."
But then you think about it for
five seconds and you're like, "No."
Yeah. Not so good. And couldn't
they come up with a better name
than Doppelganger for an evil spider?
Right.
You know?
And you don't want to dissect this stuff...
Aren't there a lot of poisonous
spider out there in the world?
Yeah.
A lot of them.
Any of the ones that come from Australia.
You don't want to go too deep into it,
but at the same time, the fact that he just keeps
showing up and that he's basically an animal. He's
this nasty... He's barely sentient, if at
all. That means that somebody is special
ordering costumes for him, because
he's always in the Spider-Man outfit.
He's wearing a six armed Spider-Man
outfit with a hole for his mouth.
A six armed Spider-Man outfit, which is...
I don't know where you shop for that.
Some Amazon delivery person is like,
"Why am I delivering all of these
Spider-Man costumes someone's stitching into one?"
We've got a pretty good idea where
Doppelganger's going to show again.
Yeah. And he's got Prime shipping.
That's my pick.
That's a good pick.
Although he could have been stood in for by any
of the '90s too scary, too many fangs characters.
There's a lot of them.
We're up to like 90 symbiotes. It's
exhausting. But which one did you pick, then?
Well, speaking of the nineties, I just
want to run through a few more of the
ones on this list here. We've got the Jackal
on our list, who, I understand why he's here.
He probably didn't start out quite so bad,
but he just became this pain in the ass,
where he's like, "I've cloned you
Spider-Man." And he's like, "Ah, I got
to deal with this clone." And then he's like,
"Guess what? I cloned the clone, Spider-Man."
I did it again.
Right. And then he's like, "I
cloned myself, Spider-Man."
Would you like to see my favorite thing that the
Jackal ever created, my favorite creation of his?
Yes, please.
Do you remember Fleer trading
cards from back in the day?
Sure.
Now see that guy right there. His name's
Shockleganger. It's not. It's Doppel
Shock. Shockleganger is my... I mean,
I wish that they'd called him that.
Oh, man.
No, it's Doppel Shock, it says.
It is Doppel Shock.
Shockleganger's funnier.
They're both good.
Thank you.
For the trading cards, they made a Jackal
clone thing that he had created that was a
combination of the Doppelganger and the
Shocker, which gives me the opportunity
to say Doppelshocker at work. And that's
my contribution to today's conversation.
And he's all about cloning,
which is not really something that jackals
have a lot to do with. So he's off theme-
I was just going to ask.
... for starters. He's a scientist
who's like, "I'm a Jackal." Why?
I've never heard his storyline put in such
succinct terms, and that is the funniest...
It's true.
I love that. Now all of a sudden I love this
character. "I did it again, Spider-Man."
Yeah. And one of the clones-
"And speaking of again, here's another
me." I love this. This is great.
One of his clones is also on our
list and his name is Spidercide,
because he kills all the
spider clones. So he sucks.
Oh, like homicide.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought S-I-D-E.
Totally get where you're coming from.
But my pick is actually none of these items on the
list. I picked one, I went off menu for this one.
It's a character that's been brought up by a
podcast duo that I really like, Mr Sunday Movies,
Weekly Planet guys James and Mason. They mention
this Spider-Man bad guy a lot, and I like him for
the reason that he is very dumb. And if you look
up any... Ours is the only list that doesn't seem
to list this guy, which we should probably rectify
immediately. It's a villain named Big Wheel.
Big Wheel.
Tom, are you familiar with Big Wheel?
I know Big Wheel. Big Wheel and the
Rocket Racer, they go hand in hand, baby.
That's right. So the story of Big Wheel is that
there's this guy, Jackson Weele, W-E-E-L-E.
That's his name.
That's his name. His name is Weele, Jackson
Weele. And he hires this villain Rocket Racer,
who has a superpowered jet skateboard,
and he rides around New York City
doing crimes. He hires him to get
these incriminating documents.
Does he do any night?
He looks so miserable.
Jackson Weele is a businessman
and he was just like-
No, I'm just so irritated that
his name is Weele. I hate that.
I mean, that's what they do. Well, but wait,
no, it actually ties into his story, so hang on.
His name was Peter Spider.
It gets better. No, no, no, no,
no, no, wait. It gets better.
So he hires Rocket Racer to get these
documents, and he does. And then he's like,
"Wait, you don't have the most incriminating
document here." And Rocket Racer's like,
"I know. I'm going to blackmail you now. Gotcha."
And so Jackson Weele is like, "Ooh, you got me."
"I'm so mad I could build a big wheel."
Well, so what happens is when Rocket Racer
is taunting Jackson Weele, he's like,
"I got you now, you big wheel." Because he's
like a big businessman, he calls him big wheel.
So then Jackson Weele goes to the
Tinkerer who is the super villain
invention guy. He says, "I got to
get this Rocket Racer. I'm so mad
when he's always calling me big wheel." And
the Tinkerer goes, "That gives me an idea."
Wait a minute. Something big...
I'd pay $100 an hour to watch
Brian act out plots of comic books.
And so gives him a giant wheel
made of steel.
Is it like a Ferris wheel or like a bike wheel?
I shared it in the chat, so if you look at our
chat, there's the cover of his first appearance.
Now, Nina, you're not familiar with
the character, so let me help you
out here. What you want to look for here
is the great big wheel. Do you see that?
Oh, I didn't see it at first,
and now I do. So thank you.
So Spider-Man and Rocket Racer are fighting,
and all of a sudden this goon shows up in a
giant wheel and he starts chasing Rocket Racer.
And Spider-Man's like, "I don't know what's
going on." And so eventually Spider-Man,
he starts fighting Rocket Racer again on a
rooftop, and Big Wheel goes up the building to get
after Rocket Racer. And then they move out of the
way, and Big Wheel falls into the Hudson River.
So there he is. He's shown up a few more times
since then, but he's always basically a dope.
Nina, I'm so sorry.
Yeah. So that's my pick for-
No, I'm not sorry because now
I know that Big Wheel exists.
Big Wheel.
Big old wheel.
The guy's a big wheel.
And you know what? It justifies my
fear of Ferris wheels, which was originally
due to heights and is now due to crime.
Yeah. Imagine if a Ferris wheel tried to commit
a crime. It'd probably go a
little something like that.
I've pivoted in my phobia.
Thanks for watching. Please
hit like and subscribe. Bye.